um I have to say I'm a little less
lonely than I was a few minutes ago but
um uh hopefully we'll get another
another couple of our folks in here so
hang tight
representative soucy will be here but
he's on his way back from a dental
appointment and uh he'll be here in a
bit but I think uh out of respect for
the folks who are here in a timely
manner we should get underway
um since this is not a
official
um it's a subcommittee meeting but it is
a subcommittee meeting where we are
looking to hear from
um interested parties in this uh this
bill for public sector OSHA
um uh
I'll just do a little introduction and
then I'll be opening the floor to uh the
folks here who um want to provide some
input
um just for for a little bit of
background
um this will be perhaps repetitious from
last week what this bill does is it uh
um replaces the New Hampshire Department
of Labor's safety standards with the
OSHA 1910 safety standards
um it does not this is what the bill
does not do is create a
um an OSHA state plan for New Hampshire
that has been contemplated but the study
committee that met a year ago reached
the conclusion that we didn't want to go
that far at this point we wanted to
Simply update the the safety standards
the New Hampshire Department of
Department Department of Labor safety
standards have really been updated or
really addressed in any substantial way
for 10 or more years and um rather than
trying to update them
in a comprehensive way
these study committee thought it would
be more
more appropriate and more complete to
Simply adopt the OSHA standards
um
effectively we don't even need to tell
OSHA that we're doing this
we're just adopting the standards the
States of Maine and Massachusetts
followed a similar path
with regard to
their trip to having a state plan
um
they adopted the OSHA standards for for
their safety standards and lived under
them for I'm not sure how many years but
some number of years and then later on
decided that they wanted to look at
adopting the state plan
um there's no commitment or indication
that we will ever do that we may we may
not but it's for definitely a different
time
and another point of emphasis is that
once these standards are adopted it will
still be our department of labor and our
department of labor inspectors who are
enforcing those standards they will do
so in the same manner that they've
enforced the New Hampshire standards or
the department of labor standards and
I'm pleased and proud to say that we
have a very
um uh a non-punitive Department of Labor
they will
um you know uh
hand out fines when uh when necessary
and appropriate but more generally if
they find a
a problem they're more focused on
solving the problem rather than
um sending out fines so that's what our
department of labor is about they will
continue to be like that they will
simply have a more comprehensive set of
Standards last point before I open it up
um because the New Hampshire Department
of Labor standards are
substantially incomplete
there are times when inspectors will
find a situation that is clearly unsafe
and it's clearly not addressed in the
department of labor standards
what they will do in those instances is
lean on the general duties clause which
is sort of a catch-all it's a clause
that basically says things ought to be
safe out there folks and
um with the and often what they will do
in backing that up is they'll look to
the OSHA standards and and and see if
the OSHA has something often it does so
the Department of Labor is already using
OSHA standards in some instances
um and um
this will simply put everyone on notice
that those are the standards that will
be applied and um frankly in my view
it's unfair
to
um find a safety uh violation
and then go to a standard that's not
cited in our statutes
um so um
I believe once these standards are
adopted by New Hampshire it'll everyone
will be on notice these are the
standards that we're all going to follow
um and in our department will continue
to be more educational and punitive so
with that I know there's several folks
who want to uh I have a say what I ask
is since we're not doing pink cards and
all that stuff when you come up identify
yourself I'm going to get your name down
and what organization you represent so
um the floor is open
good morning Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is Michael Fitzgerald
I am the assistant director of the air
division at the Department of
Environmental Services
and uh with me also today is Mike little
Mike is the uh manager of our air
monitoring program uh
we operate a network of 13 air
monitoring stations around the state uh
to monitor air quality provide data to
us to to put out forecasts you may hear
when there's poor air quality this
summer you probably heard a lot about
the Quebec wildfires and and we
collected a lot of data and information
and we're able to put that out just you
know on your weather forecast sometimes
you get the air quality forecast a lot
of that information comes from us the
information that we gather is also used
to determine the state's compliance with
Federal standards for air quality and to
ensure that we are meeting those
standards or if we're not meeting them
to determine what we need to do in order
to meet them a lot of the pollution
comes from Cars and Trucks
factories power plants Etc and so our
network of monitors is is around the
state and it's placed magically and
approved by EPA to make sure that we're
monitoring appropriately we can't
monitor everywhere but the network is is
intended to be uh
representative of air quality throughout
the state and and in certain particular
locations
so with that a few years ago we became
aware of a requirement under OSHA
standards and the national electrical
code called nrtl
nationally recognized Testing
Laboratories
and I can send the committee some
website information it's an OSHA program
but basically when you purchase a piece
of electrical equipment and it has an
underwriter's laboratory
UL sticker on it that's what we're
talking about nrt
UL Underwriters Laboratory is an nrtl a
nationally recognized testing Laboratory
and under that program
um and again we're not experts we do
have electricians on staff and and but
we we're not experts in this area we
have consulted with
um the uh Folks at the department of
safety the electrical code folks
um on on this issue but uh it appears to
us that uh under the under these OSHA
standards this nrtl listing is required
for what's uh what it refers to as
instruments
we have not been able to make an
ultimate determination as to whether
some of the highly sophisticated
instrumentation that we have is subject
to this requirement or not but we have
assumed that it that it is again so a
lot of this equipment is extremely
sophisticated it's it's takes
samples of air measures the the
particulate matter or ozone or other
chemical components and transmits that
data back to our our offices and
the instrumentation
is not your average every day it's not a
limp or a heater or washing machine or
whatever some of these are twenty thirty
thousand forty thousand dollar
instruments and some of them come from
outside of the United States they're the
only ones that are certified by EPA we
currently have uh you know
hundreds of thousands if not millions of
dollars of equipment deployed around the
state and the vast majority of it is
nrtl certified does have some type of a
label from from the uh and I have a
listing here of all the nrtls as I say
one UL is one of them that's the one
that you're probably most familiar with
um but some of our instrumentation is 10
15 years old and is is not and has never
been certified we have actually sent
some of our instrumentation out to uh
and paid for it to be certified and our
policy is to only purchase nrtl
certified equipment if possible however
there are certain cases and and I would
defer to Mike here but over the last
several years
we've most of the equipment that we've
purchased has been available as nrtl
certified and we have
um
put that in our spec for purchasing when
we work with the Department of
purchasing here in the state Das and I
think in general we have not had any
issues with new equipment that that has
not been nrtl certified
um so this is an issue we just wanted to
put on your radar screen to
um to understand that we do have some
equipment it would be extremely costly
to replace we do you know every 10 or 15
years we turn equipment over and and
purchase new equipment but we do have
some equipment that may not be in RTL
certified
and um
we would just seek for the Committees to
take considerate take that into
consideration and perhaps allow the
Department of Labor in its whatever
rulemaking they have to do following
this
to
Grant an exemption for uh for some of
this equipment
um again it's not your
not your everyday off the shelf you know
just go down to Lowe's and purchase an
air monitor
um and uh
um so that's our situation I'd be happy
to take questions on uh
any any of these concerns and again
we're just looking to have this this
recognized and and perhaps some
allowance made for in case we need to
purchase this equipment
um in the future and we're not able to
get it in RTL certified it may be made
in Sweden or somewhere like that and
they
um and again we we would be happy we do
we have actually bought equipment and
paid to have it certified if that if if
it's possible so
um we're not trying to get away uh
without uh meeting these requirements um
there are just certain very
uh
specialized cases that might need some
attention thank you
um I'm going to ask the Department of
Labor to to weigh in uh but first are
there questions from the other members
of the committee
okay
um not sure who's who's
um
up at bat but uh is is the Department of
Labor willing to weigh in on this
thank you thank you
good morning Representatives I'm happy
to take any questions on what was just
testified too well I I guess uh the uh
the question that I would have is we've
heard a detailed explanation as to what
the the issue is
um it sounds you know a very legitimate
concern from the Department of
Environmental Services
um can you give some idea as to how the
Department of Labor would handle
um a situation like that unless I think
first of all one it would depend on
um you know what the equipment actually
is without knowing what it is
um whether it fits in with the
requirements how far off it is it's
tough to say Obviously a lot of these
things are going to be a case-by-case
basis the other point being that as was
testified to if the legislature were to
give the department rulemaking authority
to provide exemptions of course then we
could consider that again we would have
to weigh it against how far from the
actual requirements of Osha the
equipment is and I would say as I think
I testified to last week the caveat with
all of this is anything shifting from
this as far as exemption goes as far as
rule making for the Department may have
to be considered in the future if the
intent in the future is to go to a full
OSHA state plan because that may impact
OSHA actually accepting the plan
obviously that's down the line but I
think it's something that should be
considered nonetheless I I would say for
the purposes today let's not even think
about this estate plan because it's uh
it's off the table so
I'm the direct
safety unit excuse me falls under my
supervision
So currently under our current law if
someone is operating Machinery uh the
obligations they operate it
um
in good condition maintaining the
Machinery in good condition use it under
all machine gartering guarding necessary
to operate it and make sure the machine
guarding is under is in good condition
and they are required to operate it as
prescribed by the manual the operation
manual so for example if the you know
saw has to be maintained at a horizontal
um trajectory if they're using it to saw
something in a vertical no
um that's that would be something that
they would that would be in violation of
our standards
um if an OSHA requirement makes it more
formal in excess of the manual then that
would be what we would hold them
accountable to the 1910 requirements
okay thank you
um any anything else from the committee
it's coming back
so
tell me tell me how you get to OSHA
covering equipment
when we have no OSHA standard for public
sector
how is it that we make how is it right
now this draw those connections so I
just wanted to correct something so
there is a general duties Clause that is
correct but the general duties Clause
that controls an employer's obligation
so an employer is expected under Twitter
and a64.
where the general duties Clause is
captured to um oversee you know evaluate
their um what their work what what are
they requiring their employees to do and
they have to keep it in they have a
general duty to provide all safety
equipment that they need to for them to
do their work safely
so when we go in
if it's not something specifically
enumerated under the 1400s or 277a we
then look to 277 17 and 18. so 277 17
and 18.
um allow us to allow for a mod to modify
a person's safety program so under 281
sorry 281 a64 all employers are required
to have a safety program so they've
looked at their what they're entitled
intending for their employees to do
they've evaluated and they've created a
program for them to do it safely to
include training and discipline and
oversight and chain of command for
communication between managers and
supervisors and employees to maintain a
general safe work environment in
conjunction with the joint Loss
Management committee
um
so if they are not so they are to
evaluate the workforce figure out all of
the the
um problems that they can foresee and
then provide it and maintain it safely
when we go in if we see it there's
something that's not safe
and we don't have a specific law under
277 or the 1400 rules to control
we then can go to this 277 17 and 18
which is where it provides us to put to
um to order additional safeguards or to
modify their safety program
we don't often go to OSHA for those I
just wanted to correct that
oftentimes what we find is that there's
a common sense or breakdown of
communication that needs to be tweaked
in a safety program so for example
there was a recent death of a state
trooper
and what we found after we did our
investigation under 277 15-b the serious
bodily injury investigation uh was that
there was just a breakdown of
communication between Dot and dos as to
where this Trooper was supposed to
report to communicate and find out where
to safely park there is no specific
statue that would not fall under OSHA
either but there is a statute under dots
um statutory rulings that say that dot
controls all work sites so there we
provided a an additional safeguard that
we want under 277 I believe it's 18 that
all state troopers need to be educated
with respect to the dot statute that dot
controls and they're supposed to report
to the Dot site manager and find out
where to safely Park that wouldn't have
been and most of our cases are like that
where it there really is some sort of
breakdown of communication or something
that the employer did not foresee in
their safety program that needs to be
tweaked so most of the time we do not
get to OSHA but we would you know if we
find a situation that's not addressed by
any one of our state laws we then can
suggest an additional Safeguard and we
can go to another resource like OSHA but
again we try to find something that
makes the most sense in the most
efficient way possible so
um
you know if there's you know if we don't
go for the most extreme
um safety requirement in all of our
recommendations we go for the one that
will get the job done
thank you
all right
and so so the way that you get to osher
um
is that you you develop your own safety
plan as I understand it no the employer
develops their safety plans I guess I'm
an environmental services okay yeah so
you have your own safety plan
right now our concern is that this
legislation passes and
uh we would then be subject to these
requirements under the Department of
Labor as they would continue to be able
to uh certification so right now we we
feel you know we're not subject to this
communication
inspectors and so on I had a brief
conversation with someone at the
Department of Labor a year to go on this
um but uh
concern is that if this legislation will
control
and and what we want to make sure is
that the department has what it's it
needs in order to implement this
um and what I'm hearing is uh some
rule-making Authority would be of some
help to you folks in order to make
exceptions and uh and such is that
correct
so the um yes there would be room making
Authority needed for exceptions but I
again there's
exceptions only go so and that could be
tricky too so if you're trying to set a
standard then you allow for Exceptions
there can be a slippery slope so I just
I I hear you what I'm trying to make you
sure I mean it sounds like the
Department of Environmental Services has
a legitimate uh concern and we want to
make sure that that concern can be
addressed and um I I guess we need to
work with you folks to figure out how we
do that
um because
um
we want to make sure you're able to
continue doing the good work that you do
um and uh simply have an upgraded set of
standards
um so uh that's that's on my list of
things to work on so
we'll be in touch
thank you
um don't don't get too comfortable
because uh you'll be back
oh I'm sorry
thank you for taking my question uh
just a general question if we adopt the
OSHA standards would it make your job
easier
so
to
no
so you know the the answer for that is
um
so OSHA standards they are constantly
changing and they incorporate things by
reference as well so the wholesale
adoption of 1910 is going to be very
complicated for our constituents you
know to follow so we're going to have to
be able to hire more staff who's who are
going to be able to read interpret
federal law and then reduce it to a
level that can be understood by a
non-attorney
um
so and then on stay on top of it because
again they are constantly changing so
one of the questions that we would have
is when they in court when 1910
incorporates things by reference when
the federal government updates those
reference points what's going to happen
with our laws will it just be frozen the
time of adoption and you know so that we
do have current laws like that where
we've adopted a federal
um
opinion of opinions a loose term but uh
from 2014 and then that's that's been
where we've stayed
um going forward
um but what will it look like uh in 1910
is a question I have with you guys uh is
will it be an evolving thing in which uh
we will constantly have to be uh staying
on top of the evolution of the federal
government or you know or is it
something in which it will remain
Frozen so that you know we have the
ability to educate and keep consistency
with the people that we're trying to
serve
I I guess what I would suggest is that
one of the problems we're addressing
today is the fact that the standards
have been frozen for um for over 10
years
um so I don't know that we would want to
get into a situation where we would be
freezing them again
um at the 2023
um state so
um I I think one of the attractive
aspects of doing this to me is is that
there will be a continuous upgrade to
the safety standards so 20 years from
now we will find that we are operating
under up-to-date modern uh safety
standards
um that's one of the main reasons for
doing this we haven't been upgrading the
standards in New Hampshire this will
maintain continuous upgrades it's
yep
thank you for taking my question
um
what I'm not certain about and I guess I
would like some clarification on is
when there's a situation where a state
public entity is subcontracting out to a
private entity and they are in essence
working side by side on a job
and the private entity has an accident
on the job and OSHA is there to
investigate the accident
where what's the position of the state's
team that was also on that job and does
OSHA start to investigate them or are
you falling under a completely different
standard while the private contractor
who's working for you is now being
investigated by OSHA that happens now
um so so
um currently what happens is OSHA will
look at it from the lens of the private
employer we will look at it from the
lens of the private employees Public
Employee or and the danger that may or
may not impact the employees so an
example is we were investigating a
serious bodily injury at the Keen
wastewater treatment plant they had
hired an electrical contractor to come
in and do some work
uh that electrical contractor
um was electrocuted and was deceased so
that caused an investigation under 277
15b for us even though it impacts a a
private contractor it still triggers
that where the public employer has to
contact us and let us know within eight
hours we went in and OSHA worked
alongside us
and OSHA we shared data and things that
you know investigatory notes uh and we
were they were looking at it was was
that employee that public sorry private
employer you employee utilizing all
safety standards their answer was no
what we were looking at was what did the
our public employer know about that
private subcontractor uh when they hired
them
um did they so that because when they
hired that you know potentially
dangerous employer uh private employer
uh they may have been creating a
dangerous condition for our public
employees so you know did they know that
that person had a bad reputation as
being a cowboy not utilizing
um proper safety gear when their
employees responded to that emergency
did they respond in accordance with
their training you know did they shut
down the electrical power before they
started to engage in and enter that room
which had been electrified how close
were the automatic defibrillator devices
so you know because again we have to put
the although it happened to a private
employee employee
we have to put you know imagine so that
we're a public employee that was on that
floor
um so how quickly can uh the that Public
Employee render be given Aid so um so so
we are basically doing the OSHA type
inspection not to you know to our
standards
um you know looking at it from both the
response and you know the from the shoes
of an employee being on that floor
Public Employee being on that floor
being the victim and also the other
public employees had to engage with that
subcontractor I don't know if that made
sense
um
uh thank you for that and did make sense
let's go back to the dot situation
um where the dot I believe you said sets
the standards for the safety standards
of where the um their traffic you know
their traffic so there are times that
dot hires private entities and I've seen
that so um what happens if a flagger is
injured on the on the job who is a
private entity working for the dot under
the dot standards who then is
responsible for for that accident
with so if there if there are public
employees also working at that job site
so if dot is simply outsourced it and
and there you know the the
um construction is being done by an
outside contractor it doesn't fall under
our authority to maintain a safe work
environment because no Public Employee
could be there at that job site now if a
Public Employee could for instance if
they retain oversight uh and that's just
something we would call about you know
if they retain oversight and control and
they're routinely going to the job site
to you know see how it's you know make
sure it's staying on track then then it
could fall under jurisdiction to figure
out you know what the nature of the
Accident Injury and could it impact a
public employee
okay
thank you
okay another one coming
um
so in the in the case of the
SE spoke about King
who has jurisdiction
dual
so they would have jurisdiction so that
we can't order the private employer to
retrain their employees to utilize
proper safety standards under OSHA that
would be falling under OSHA
for us we would put probably an
additional Safeguard or modification if
we found out that they hadn't checked
references uh if they if the electrified
person the deceased person the victim ha
didn't have a license why didn't you
chat you know you know you should be
hiring only licensed people and maybe
there would be additional safe order
modification issued by us
um under 277 17 and 18.
um
if we found that the um the employees
didn't know how to render Aid or didn't
have a safety plan in place for
responding to emergencies our laws
already control that we would say you
have to create a safety program that
accounts for that and that would fall
under us under our jurisdiction because
OSHA would not have jurisdiction to jump
into our world
and is it fair to say that uh this
rather complex interaction
um that you presently
um experience would continue
um regardless of whether or not we adopt
OSHA safety standards
um yeah what the same relationship would
continue right
I just want to be clear that I mean it's
interesting to uh be aware of those
interactions
um but they will they'll carry on
because there will still be an OSHA and
there will still be a New Hampshire
Department of Labor responsible for
private on one side public on the other
side I think that would agree I know we
weren't supposed to discuss OSHA state
but I think that would even occur up
here in an ocean
still be dual investigators coming in us
being in the shoes of an OSHA state
employee and the OSHA state employee for
the private
um that's what I understand
it's a final question
um
so is that double jeopardy for a
employer so now we have the state has
jurisdiction the federal government has
jurisdiction both of you can proceed
against the the company is that right no
so I'm only looking at the public I'm
only looking at Key and Wastewater
OSHA's looking at Mr electricity Inc
um so you know and so our cases are
separate and apart and going in
completely different directions
thank you
we good yeah
okay the floor is open to other folks
annoy people from the counties uh
available today
um
I see my my friend from Sullivan County
coming up
if you could both identify yourselves
and who you are and what you're from
where you're from
Hillary snide I'm the Director of Human
Resources for Sullivan County
and I'm Mary Burke I'm the director of
facilities and operations for Sullivan
County
um
I think it's important to note I've
spent more than 18 years of my
professional career within the
facilities management industry both in
the private sector for 12 years and uh
in the public sector at Sullivan County
for the last six years
um Sullivan County takes the safety of
your employees seriously and our
opposition to HB 232 is not to imply
otherwise however we do have some
concerns in the adoption of 1910 OSHA so
as we've heard New Hampshire DOL
enforces RSA 277 and other
administrative rules to protect public
employees and due to these due to the
varied nature of the work that counties
do to provide services to the
communities our safety programs are very
decentralized based on those diverse
options and our work is also governed by
other safety rules and regulations
enforced by other agencies is like the
EPA NFPA and Department of Health and
Human Services amongst others in fact
more than two-thirds of the Sullivan
County's 300 employees work in Sullivan
County healthcare our nursing home which
is subject to on-site licensing survey
every year done in person by New
Hampshire DHHS and it holds us to a
higher operating standard than OSHA
because of this annual in-person
evaluation
our training records on subjects like
emergency evacuation bloodborne
pathogens and workplace chemicals are
examined as part of that audit with
deficiencies given when training is
found to not be satisfactory
so current state rules and regulations
do not prescribe training requirements
or frequencies on most topics like 1910
OSHA does
OSHA details specific training topics
that must be covered sets forth training
frequencies and requires training to be
given by qualified instructors
in 1910 21
OSHA defines qualified as a person who
by possession of a recognized degree
certificate or professional standing or
by extensive knowledge training and
experience has successfully demonstrated
the ability to solve or resolve problems
related to the subject matter the work
or the project
while we have some of our safety
training completed by outside resources
a large majority of our safety training
is done by our own supervisors or
in-house trainers
while demonstrated ability in the OSHA
standard does provide some leeway it is
very ambiguous from a risk management
perspective as to which authority would
deem someone qualified and what does
happen when Sullivan County deems an
in-house trainer to be qualified in the
Department Labor disagrees
if the intent of HB 232 is to provide
the level of protection of 1910 OSHA our
interpretation would mean that Sullivan
County would need to seek higher
credentials for our trainers in
additional outside sources at higher
cost
although not mandatory by OSHA Sullivan
County looks to OSHA's recommended 10
hour and 30-hour training thresholds for
General employees and supervisors and
Specialty staffs respectively as
guidance for the level of training
necessary to comply with the spirit of
1910.
to manage additional training
requirements keep up with ever-changing
federal regulations
credentialing training our own training
resources and additional record-keeping
requirements the county anticipates the
need to create an additional full-time
management position of health and safety
manager
we looked at two local job listings
within 20 miles of our facility and
found
um
two private firms that were looking for
the same type of position and it was
listed at a salary starting salary of
seventy to eighty thousand dollars
before benefit which we would
um
expect to be approximately a hundred and
fifty thousand dollars annually of
Burden employment costs to the county
additional costs and time are of a
significant concerns to us at the county
when you look at HB 232 the fiscal note
indicates that this will cause
additional costs to the county and the
full Financial impact may not be
identified until a compliant program is
written adopted and implemented
HP 232 does not include an appropriation
for any costs incurred by local
officials
60 days also too in terms of the
implementation is unreasonable it will
most likely take the county two to three
years to create and Implement a program
that we believe to be comply compliant
with OSHA 1910.
to do that a new program will require
staff
evaluation and development of our
current programs
engaging in outside cons consultant
safety consultant to also evaluate our
programs against the 1910 standard
we would from a risk management point of
view complete a risk assessment and
engage legal counsel to make sure that
our program was compliant
and then conduct the expanded training
before every employee could be deemed to
be protected at the same level as 1910
OSHA
these points also don't consider the
potential impacts on the physical
facilities and equipments that would
need to be acquired improved or replaced
as it would be a huge undertaking for us
at this time to even inspect our
facilities and Equipment against the
current requirements
that would lead us to
um not understanding the true impact of
the passage of this legislation until it
was implemented
so lastly I believe the intent of HB 232
is ultimately to improve safety for New
Hampshire's public sector workers
the more common injuries to public
employees result from student
interactions law enforcement struggles
combative residents and slips and Falls
due to weather conditions adopting 1910
OSHA as a whole does little to address
these injury sources and creates an
additional burden to taxpayers without
significant benefits from the rules and
regulations that are already in place
HP 232 seeks out to replace out-of-date
rules and regulations with a different
existing Federal standard but I believe
this bill as written is not the right
solution and encourage the committee to
explore Alternatives other than
holistically adopting uh 1910 OSHA
thank you thank you um questions from
the
thank you for coming for all your
experience that you bring to the table
we appreciate that
currently there are millions of people
covered by ocean
millions of people
hundreds of thousands of companies that
have that are covered by OSHA including
some states that currently enter the
state total
so my question is you mentioned various
agencies that you're currently various
federal agencies that have jurisdiction
over some of your work
and that was NFPA I think you mentioned
that there was a couple of other that a
couple other teachers mentioned so those
are federal standards and NFPA I was a
firefighter as was my colleague here uh
so we're familiar with the NFPA
standards and
they have been game changers in a lot of
ways and many of the people in the
industry but it is a it is a National
Standard and you have been able to been
able to go through and adapt your
operation to accommodate the changes as
they happen with some of these other
organizations so it's a question my
question to you is it a matter of
startup
the fear of starting up a new program
and uh and not understanding completely
what the implications will be and what
the potential uh costs will be is that
so it's not so much at the standard
you're not post a standard is that
correct
um
um really so it's not necessarily it's
not lack of fear I will say that
um what it is it really it does boil
down to the startup and it also boils
down to the fact the reference to other
Federal standards that we do comply with
um was meant to indicate that there's
already oversight on New Hampshire
public employees because of licensing
requirements and other regulations that
are out there so so
um this would be above and beyond
and duplicative in a lot of cases to
statutes that we already comply with
the startup is a large concern because
of the fact that
um the county has not Fallen under OSHA
requirements when our safety programs
were
developed they were developed
distributed across the county where for
example the nursing home developed their
only their own safety program
Corrections is a different industry so
they developed their own safety program
and so to say that the county has one
safety program isn't necessarily true
versus a business that has one objective
making widgets per se
has one operation or one purpose that
they are really considered that they
have to consider for developing their
programs and so we have several
different programs within the county
that we would have to redo
and take a look at how our operations
would change and so those safety
programs were built to not
to comply with 1910 they were built to
comply with local regulations and other
um
for example other nursing home receives
Medicaid and Medicare funds so they're
subject to the Center for Medicaid and
Medicaid services requirements for
licensing and that's a whole different
set of requirements that a lot of times
are duplicative
and so what we look at is is the initial
cost to comply with 1910 is basically
rewriting our program to meet a
different standard that we feel is much
more onerous than the current standards
without providing much more benefit to
those within the county
so it would be initial and ongoing costs
of value if we were to move be able to
move down the road with this is there
some value in and it may be shared by
the counties getting together
considering they offer I'm a
Hillsborough and uh you know so we do
the nursing home we do the prison we do
a lot of those other services is it
value and creating some kind of
um coordinating Council that would help
with implementation and maybe you could
share some of the costs associated with
this as well maybe there's just one
expert you have to hire that helps all
these places so I'm just trying to
figure out how if the startup is a big
problem it's some way to make this a
more gentle
we actually do across the counties
confer quite a bit through the New
Hampshire Association of counties there
are also subgroups of county level
leadership for the different divisions
within the county through nhac so we
share information quite a bit regarding
policies and procedures across the
counties like that so I maybe it's a
little bit more informally than creating
a specific committee for something like
this but we often share information
I'll just I'll just reflect back on your
comment of fear I think that's a strong
word but carefully considering the
impact to our staff what does it mean to
current staff any potential to add
future staff coming from a HR standpoint
we've all talked about employment in the
state of New Hampshire unemployment
rates and finding staff so any
consideration for All Counties to have
to restructure or build a health and
safety program that would require
specialized trainers to be hired by all
of us there's some fear in that do those
people exist for all of us to access
that's a component to the conversation
also we carefully consider our
compliance and relationship I do like to
think it's a partnership with Department
of Labor but we in Human Resources
that's the the bread and butter of what
we do is compliance with Department of
Labor so you can tell we've carefully
scrutinized what this would mean for us
financially and on staff and then if we
think about that work that needs to be
done do we have the staff in the state
to help us do that work to be compliant
and if if so does it exist in the
timeline we're talking about so just to
add that in is there some fear in there
that these people exist for us to access
right away yeah in Human Resources
there's always fear that do our staff
exist right now
um so I'll just add that but thank you
for all the work I know from
Hillsborough County's perspective how
difficult it is the challenges that
you're facing Staffing and all those
other things so thank you for our
YouTube well one thing I would like to
uh acknowledge is and this is something
that we discussed at length earlier in
the year
um the Implement implementation date UH
60 days
um is too soon and I think
um our committee has acknowledged that
we've not uh pinned down an exact
effective date yet but uh
um it's it will not well
I'm sure it will not be 60 days it'll be
substantially longer than that to give
give the time that folks will need to
get ready so
um yeah 1910 is a pretty length the set
of regulations and so from a
implementation and risk management point
of view it would require us as a county
to go line by line to determine how we
comply and how we train our people to
understand and comply and make sure that
and just ensure how we do that with a
program
takes time to evaluate let alone uh
change and implement
so we appreciate you taking a look at
the um
the implementation time right okay
thank you thank you
I think what we'll do is get more County
people up uh sort of run
run throughout the county people and
perhaps in the Department of Labor can
respond to some of the uh issues that
are raised okay thank you good morning
my name is David Ross and I am the
nursing home administrator for
Hillsborough County Nursing Home thank
you for making the time today for us to
come and speak with you I won't repeat
any of the information that was shared
by Sullivan County
I think they were extremely articulate
in defining the issues but I wanted to
address a couple of key things for us we
are not
um so concerned I think we're fearful of
new regulations we deal with new
regulations all of the time
um I think what we're concerned about
for us at least in the nursing home
sector is unnecessary regulation in the
burdens that it that it creates
we do have many standards that we have
to comply with NFPA being a big one CMS
regulations and by reference many OSHA
standards already many of the references
that we have on follow industry
standards of practice that we have to
meet and we by reference then defer to
OSHA guidelines for implementation of
many of those things
the pieces that aren't included in those
cross references are the specific
references to qualified individuals
training and documentation requirements
um that are specified in the 1910
standards which are overburdensome for
us
um and aren't going to achieve any of
the safety objectives of this proposed
legislation and those do come at an
additional cost for us Sullivan County
is absolutely correct that it will
require at least one if not more than
one new management position established
to be able to both develop and evaluate
and monitor compliance with these new
standards it is a voluminous job prior
to coming to Hillsborough County I
worked in the private sector and in many
different organizations and there were
entire departments dedicated to this
very
facet of operations to manage risk
management and OSHA compliance and these
regulations are voluminous
labor is a big issue for us and
dedicating an additional time to the
training resources that are required
here both from finding qualified
trainers having to pay for them but more
importantly dedicating time for our
limited Personnel to engage in this
training in a meaningful way is going to
be hard for us to accomplish we are
struggling very realistically with
Workforce challenges and to add to the
burden of additional training over and
above what we're already doing
is very very concerning for us at this
time and I just really want to emphasize
that point
um I do know at the beginning of today's
session you did reference that this
legislation does not impose OSHA
enforcement
um on on the state or on the
municipalities or counties I will point
out that throughout each of the
subsections of the 1910 standard it does
Grant authority of access for the
Secretary of
um the of a Russia to be able to have
access to information and I would be
concerned that there has to be some
language in our own statute that
withdraws that or removes that
um so I will point out the subparts Z
specifically
1910.1020
addresses access unto employee medical
records for exposure events
um
so it has to be make sure that we're not
opening a door for an enforcement action
that was unintended as we're trying to
incorporate safety standards in here
implementation timeline is critical for
us I appreciate your recognition that 60
days is not reasonable and that we would
have to look at a longer time timeline
for that
um I applaud that acknowledgment and we
would definitely be looking for a three
to five year implementation period would
be my recommendation for us
um
you did ask if counties could combine
resources to create maybe one position
that would be helped to develop these
things I think you all recognize as
Representatives that each County
operates individually
um and all of those operations are
really dedicated and directed by budgets
and and finance that one we struggle
with one elected body binding a
subsequent elected body let alone
um other counties binding other
um the obligations or requirements of
separate counties
similarly municipalities are some are
affected by this regulation so it it
would really be very different for us to
suggest that we would pull resources to
be able to create regulations that would
impact any individual County alone that
each one is going to want to make their
own specifically I can assure you that
Hillsborough County would want to make
their own
um as you see in many of the statutes
already that there's specific reference
to Hillsborough County alone so
um that's just just to share I'm happy
to answer any questions that you have
and I appreciate your time
I we all serve on County delegations yes
we kind of get it I know you do I know
you I know you do
hi Hi how are you
um
I I think it's important to uh and I've
run this by the chair but I think it's
important to note
that there was created many years ago a
Public Employee safety act
I have the file right here in fact I
helped write it great somehow it got
absorbed into the Department of Labor I
mean Nick haven't quite figured out how
that happened but he got absorbed but
the fact is that when when these
when this stuff was created
there was a whole infrastructure that
exist that we put into place that
provided support uh to the local
communities to uh businesses all
throughout the state there with if you
look back on the law there are all kinds
of things that the Department of Labor
was able to do indeed when we
implemented some of this language when
he used it so the question I have is can
the Department of Labor be if we would
be able to fund them better
would they be a resource for people like
the Hillsborough County
the nursing home or the prison or the
other counties because we did this
before it's not this is not it's done
some of this work before
so how can we help I guess and that's
I I guess it I
for me my response to that is to ask is
help really needed
um I believe that the structure that we
have now with the federal oversight that
we have and now at least in the nursing
home section sector the annual
inspection process that we have we have
life safety inspections we have health
and safety inspections and if needed we
have the Department of Labor to be
taking a look at safety programs as well
I do not believe that additional help is
needed
and I think that in implementing this
would actually be an unfunded mandate
for us at on the county level for us to
incur additional costs
um for services that aren't truly
necessary
what one thing I would remind the
committee of is that providing the
department with
better funding is not really an issue
the the Department of Labor is
self-funded so and and frankly they are
presently sending money back to the
general fund so it um if
I'll just leave it at that it's just the
reality
thank you thank you very much
thank you
um
would the department like to weigh in
and especially with regard to the issue
of training
we heard we heard some concerns about
um
what what a qualified trainer would be
and so forth and I had a conversation
with Mr Gardner yesterday
um and uh perhaps you could
provide some backgrounds yes of course
um so as it relates to a qualified
person I would say initially that
um
obviously with today's current standards
if somebody is deemed unqualified that's
training we would have issue with that
that's something we would cite
um I recognize that that's kind of
circular reasoning in that sense but you
know there are two kind of different
standards there for what makes a
qualified person under OSHA standards at
least if they're certified which I would
take to mean you know if somebody's a
plumber electrician do they have the
requisite licenses that's a very simple
test Fair obviously somebody who is not
an electrician should probably not be
training somebody on electrical work
that's an easy citation the other one
that is a little bit more amorphous and
Broad I would recognize is the second
piece of the test of whether they have
the experience necessary again though I
think all of us in general can say is
this person qualified to do this or not
do they have any experience what's the
level of experience there so as far as
the qualified person piece goes again we
as an apartment generally in today's
standards it's something that we would
recognize too we would ask who is
training saying why are they training
what are their qualifications again do
they hold the requisite licensure if
there is any licensure involved there so
again it's something that we'd be
looking at anyways I would say the OSHA
standard kind of just goes to Define
that a little bit more
um again recognizing it is rather Broad
in its sense but obviously it's
something that OSHA has been
implementing for years and it seems to
work for them but again it's something
that we would look at anyways under
today's standards
please
uh just for my understanding did you say
that if an electrician has a license or
a plumber or gas sitter has a license
that they're qualified to train for
safety in that field is that what I'm
hearing you say I would so I apologize
let me go back so I would say it's not
100 a guarantee we would still look at
it on a case-by-case basis what I would
say though is if somebody is training in
one of those fields where generally to
do the work licensure is required that
would probably be you know a key piece
that we would look to see if somebody
does have that again if somebody is
training somebody on specifically how to
perform electrical work if they did not
have an electrician's license I would
say that'd be a major red flag that they
might not be qualified from the get-go
so again it's something we would look to
I wouldn't say it's necessarily a prima
fascia case that if they have the
license they're deemed qualified again
Case by case basis for anything like
that though
the questions
uh the the current Law requires that
each Public Employee
employer in the state file a safety plan
with the Department of Labor now when
that was originally passed I think was
every year and then it was modified I
think it was every three years and now I
I don't think they have to file it again
so I'm looking at some safety plans that
were filed in 1978
um and revised of 2005. so under the
current law
um
what is the Department of Safety doing
when it comes to these plans do
employers have some responsibility to
update these plans and if that's the
case who's doing it
thank you so under this law is the
current laws they have to update them at
a minimum every two years there's also a
requirement the jlmc me quarterly so if
they're meeting quarterly and they're
notified they're being you know made
aware of dangerous or unsafe conditions
or concerns the expectation when we do a
safety audit of their business we look
at those minutes and if they're not
addressing it or or revising their plan
based on a legitimate safety concern or
not even conducting an investigation
that is something that we would discuss
with them
um so although the bare minimum
qualification you know is that they
update them every two years
um they are expected to address safety
concerns in the immediate and when we do
our audit we are looking at their safety
program as well to make sure that it
does have some notification on it that
it was updated within the last two years
uh in addition to looking at the jlmc
minutes that they are required to
maintain at these quarterly meetings to
see what they're overseeing what their
concerns are and just the current plan
address them
the the meetings that you're talking
about the quarterly meetings are the
joint Labor Management committee means
correct joint Loss Management yes so
it's the employees any employees that
was created under the law so
when is the last time can you give us
some sense of how many audits you did of
the safety plans and when the last time
is that you
so every time we go and conduct an audit
we are looking at their safety plan
so um you know so it's it's it's every
every audit we are looking at as part of
the checklist
um do they have an updated safety plan
so you do have to file the safety
summary that they've certified that
they've updated but they should be doing
it every two years and if we catch you
we're going to cite you on that so
so every again every you're saying every
employee should be updating the plan to
be two years correct and where does that
go so that is maintained with the
employer and distributed amongst the
employees
so it needs to be accessible to the
so the employees but you don't get
copies of that no we do not used to
uh we used to get the safety summary
form so they didn't actually give us the
entire plan some plans can be quite
volume so for instance Hillsborough
County plan will be multiple volumes it
would be the nursing home plan the
corrections plan and you know county
attorney's plan you know multiple
volumes
um they would provide us a summary of
each one of their locations
well just just for the record I pulled I
did a
um right to no request at Hillsborough
County plants and I can share those with
them and they're not
we've looked at them they're on our list
thank you
do we have others who um would like to
provide input
please
thank you
um the Director of Human Resources for
the city of Concord so I'm representing
the public sector as far as
municipalities go
in the city of Concord we do not have
the school district but many
municipalities do have school districts
under their uh political subsection the
reason I bring that up is and Sullivan
County did present this during their
testimony school districts do offer a
lot of our injuries within the public
sector in that Municipal subsection
uh I I'm representing the city of
Concord because I believe that the 1910
OSHA regulations
will not address worker safety which is
essential to us I am a member of our
joint Loss Management committee we do
meet every six weeks we have a very
robust and active committee that looks
at near missed incidents and it looks to
craft training and prevention and
communication before incidents increase
in severity or in um
frequency
and I think OSHA would handcuff that
effort because it would instead
Implement standards that already exists
and are very robust as you've heard and
stipulate training that has to occur in
compliance that has to occur
um whereas now we can be more Nimble and
flexible with the training that we see
needing to happen
one of the things I did to prepare for
today was to go to primex which offers
our workers compensation coverage and
they provided me with
um the most
frequent injuries that are seen in the
public sector and municipalities and
those include
injuries from student interactions
police struggles human and animal bites
combative residents and slips and falls
on ice and snow and you did hear that
from Sullivan County as opposed to the
most common OSHA citations which are
fall protection hazardous communication
that's your safety data sheets
respiratory protection ladders
scaffolding lockout tag out and powered
industrial trucks commonly known as
forklifts we feel if you look at those
two sections those two categories OSHA
versus in the public sector what you're
seeing for injuries there's not a lot of
overlap where the OSHA standards would
have addressed those particular injuries
and helped to prevent them and that's
really what our focus is with worker
safety is to look at prevention
um
you know I worked in the private sector
for 10 years at McLean in Kentucky so I
was subject to OSHA as well as the
Federal Motor Carrier safety regulations
for our CDL Drivers and I suffered a
workplace fatality of an employee and
that's something that definitely changes
you it makes you look at things
differently makes you wish that you
could go back in time and do things
differently so I don't want to appear
that safety is not of the utmost concern
to me as an HR Director but I do think
the programs that we have in place and
the Department of Labor's current safety
policies provide the framework in order
to provide a safe environment and to
allow us to be flexible and responsive
to the incidents we see
um
I think that there are other ways that
we could provide safety to our workers
in the public sector besides adopting
1910 wholesale I think that it would
require some more time and maybe carving
out what you find to be the most
important pieces of that it's been
stated by the counties very eloquently
how much the training would impact us
trying to be compliant with it when it
might not necessarily even impact those
workers safety
I had another thought but it has left me
questions from the committee
well thank you thank you
do we have others who would like to
testify
or maybe provide input it's a better way
anything further from the Department
that you'd like to uh
add to today's discussion
I guess so
I just wanted to reiterate I'm a new
attorney Gardener had already stated as
such earlier the last test time we
provided testimony we already do provide
training so we we are that Central
agency that you were talking about
earlier we provide pencil audits at
request of the employers when we do that
although it does generate a report
that's you know and a timeline for
compliance or not levying fine holding
fines above anyone's head
um
we're just we're you know it's the other
thing that we do provide is um
you know regular like I just did a
training yesterday for municipalities
with respect to setting up a safety plan
um so I you know that is something that
we do I'm not afraid of hard work I just
want to make that clear
um you know it will make it in the sense
that explaining more laws will require
more staff more trained staff higher
trained staff in the sense that they
have to be able to
um review and understand and explain uh
in common language federal laws
um
such that people can understand them
um there is I know it is true what she
said and as heard earlier testimony uh
right now people that are coming out of
school uh with understanding of both of
safety state level and OSHA are
graduating uh and can require and demand
salaries beginning at seventy thousand
dollars uh and that is going to be very
hard for us to retain
um especially given that they're all
going to be interested in picking from
that same pool of applicants
um so I just wanted to bring that to
your attention as well I did speak with
Keene State University that would their
um head administrator of the safety plan
of their of their safety program
and that is what they're commanding
before benefits and they do get
comparable benefits uh to what the state
offers that usually is our selling point
the work-life balance and our benefit
package our wonderful benefit package
um and that it does not I don't have the
edge given the current economy yeah and
and our understanding from last week was
that uh
public sector employers would likely be
leaning on the Department of Labor to
provide some implementation
um assistance so um that's
something that I think is important and
helpful correct we would be creating my
action plan if this bill were to pass
would be to create a consultation type
service would increase would need
increased Staffing to help people
transition
um and track all of these cases
um because they're they're all going to
have different needs and we do have
um currently
um we do have discretion with the amount
of time we give people to bring
themselves into compliance we don't
expect compliance overnight we are a
reasonable agency we expect just a good
faith effort yeah and as I was
as we get into this discussion of
effective dates
the date will probably not be five years
out
um that that's probably a bit too far
but the anticipation would be that
whenever the date is it will not be a um
a starting gun that goes off that says
as of today everyone's going to be
perfect
um that's not the way you folks operate
this is not how it operates currently
correct you know
do give them a reasonable amount of time
we'd understand budgetary constraints
now the excuse can't always be we you
know yes we knew about the problem but
now we got to start saving money for it
but there's
but we do communicate with them and we
we ask for updates and just as long as
we see that a person is making a good
faith effort to bring their business
into current compliance we're willing to
work with any employer
can I thank you for that
um
anything else
you know I
I heard a number of different people
come from different agencies and talk
about different standards that they
currently use and
and
the question I have is it
the is there a role at the State plays
in the sense that
we have a Target standard that everybody
is moving towards
and and I think my sense is that that's
what we're trying to do establish this
this target standard that people so
across the board whether you go from
Sullivan County Hillsborough County that
there is consistency in terms of what
the what the language
is for various standards that that we
apply
because the the impression I get and
this is difficult I understand this is
difficult to to manage but
um is there a value in having a central
standard that people operate under
I don't think there'll ever be as
you know for instance if they're
receiving federal funds they're going to
have to work under different standards
um so and you know so that we do
currently have a set standard that
everyone is supposed to follow and you
know the I think the goal of this panel
is to raise the standard
um
and so is there value to have you know
assessment yes we do currently have that
um but I don't think everyone is always
going to have uh freedom from these
outside agencies there's always going to
be safety Plus
well let me I'll just say that that
millions of employers and people around
the around the United States is covered
by OSHA and employees all over the place
have been able to manage change which is
what we're suggesting here and to keep
it standard that's going to be
it's going to age what the what the so I
I hope that we can get to a place
where public employees are covered by
the same laws as federal employees the
same protections as the federal
employees and the in the private sector
employees I hope we can get to that
place which is the point of this whole
exercise so
thank you thank you
thank you
is there anyone else uh here who would
like to provide input
we will be meeting uh next week again at
10 A.M on Thursday
um to uh
continue getting input I'm not
suggesting you folks come back and do it
again
um but I expect there will be others who
have not yet had a chance and the whole
purpose of doing this the reason we
retained the bill was because some folks
said we
um would have liked to have provided
input and I'm glad to be getting it
um and we will continue doing that uh
for a little while now so thank you for
coming we are adjourned
it